[Music]
it had to be myself just the general
being of me I don't know I'd have to
come up with questions in relation to
Who I am right now versus who I might
become versus who I have been in the
past I probably have dinner with Jesus
yeah I'd want to have like that last
stuffing I just want to see I just want
to see what was going down you know like
all the disciples and everything as
probably the famous dinner right the
most famous dinner I could think of
don't call you only I think it's a
gangster famous one just because
it's rad how he managed to pull all this
gangster stuff off not that I want to be
a gangster but it's just it's so
different from what I am and it's scary
and fascinating at the same time so yeah
definitely don't call you only Oh easy
Ozzy Osbourne because we would obviously
get along from drinking and stuff
California Gurls for sure because I love
California
I love diet lifestyle here and I love
Americans my brother max over there is
eleven normal [ __ ] or Madonna
yeah for sure so far
that's my favorite artists of all time
Lindsay fellows blonde great eyes and
Iraq's outrageous I'd invite you on
master dinner
I think he's
right I think he's a force for good in
the world and he's a revolutionary that
we don't have many of those these days
just wanna pick his brain
it would be my mom I told campus thank
you
I don't know we just get along really
well and we would talk about all the
[ __ ] that we do were not together which
is a lot of the time Sofia Vergara I was
from Colombia and making a beautiful
Obama I don't buy Obama to dinner and
when we just talked about
his presidency went I think I'm gonna go
with Jimi Hendrix a lot of his
philosophies and perspectives are
reflected in his music just having a
conversation with him over dinner with
you so enlightening actually I can say
they're off because we actually just
talked about them and ask just ask him
about anything he seems like he could do
to hang out with my wife because we
never get a chance to do it a chef
called Bernie oppressive
he's the form of dangerous run woman
which one the best restaurant in the
world like three times no I used to be
almost chefs to you once now residing
business I wanted to talk to him about
creativity in the process introducing
I would like to invite my grandpa
because he's one of my favorite persons
in the whole world
he's not here anymore but I'd like to
you know ask him a little bit more but
like probably been staples
just because he's kind of like what my
highest self wanted to be before like I
failed at that so I would want to talk
to him I feel I could just be really
inspiring we have a question that you
might want
do you ever feel lonely and how do you
cope with your loneliness Trevor Noah
because he's just so smart and funny and
know so much so I think it would be
interesting to have a conversation with
it what are his thoughts on social like
how social media is affecting people's
interaction in 2017
the way media's being disseminated as
well as just like the way people
interact you know phone snapchat
Instagram is it all too plastic these
days do people still
hold decent conversations anymore you
know like in person face to face you
know or are you gonna sit at the table
with somebody and just people getting in
Congress
I think I will take my girlfriend
because she's very close to me like
she's my girlfriend likes his decision
for my life
I thought about this before I thought
it's between a comedian because they're
funny and just so many famous just to
get it off the bucket list I think I'm
going experience so I pick a comedian
right now I'm really into like Daniel
Tosh he's hilarious
I will pick him because I just have so
many questions to ask him about you know
how he got into it how he started in
like his first show pretty private he
doesn't really live a social media life
so I have no idea what he does when he's
not on his TV show
I would pick him and if I could choose
the place to go to dinner it would be
something disgusting like he's gonna get
sick and complain the whole time about
Selena Gomez cuz she [ __ ] she [ __ ]
over Justin Bieber
[Music]
I think I'll just make it a fun one and
she's Jim Morrison's I've always you
know I just thought it'd be a perfect
guy to hang out with one evening and
then he could sit there you could tell
your poems he could sing you a song
drink some whiskey with him I guess and
you know talk about the blues
he can't be hard why I like him alone
man thank you
where's my vibrator what would you guys
talk about
but my life I thought she's like Justin
Justin Bieber cuz he slays [ __ ] okay
yeah
though I'm gonna say Jim Carrey in Ace
Ventura form and because probably
astronaut Chris Hadfield and we'd go to
like wings and things probably because
he's a nice guy
I read his book it's a good book
I would send my sister Sam she just
passed away this was like six months ago
and the reason I say that is this place
what I'm saying right now hostel is
something that reminds me a lot of her
lifestyle
it's kind of weird I just found myself
here you look right over behind us
the beach bungalow I see a lot of her in
there so I mean I'd like to spend
another dinner with you
[Music]
[Music]